Detroit used to be the bastion of
American automobile manufacturing after
a number of crises in the industry the
city's population has fallen from two
million to less than half of that but
cars are still a crucial economic factor
in the Great Lakes region
every January the north american
international auto show is held here it
features dreams of mobility molded in
metal and the guiding theme seems to be
big is beautiful lavanya a car Chester
mata scored says American companies are
putting relatively small ancients even
in their large cars the Lincoln
Navigator zanshin is only three and a
half liters but that doesn't make it
environmentally friendly ecological
alternatives do exist but their share of
the market is modest the Daimler
subsidiary smart has brought out the
third generation of its electrically
powered model which has enjoyed
increasing success dimension smart CEO
aneta ving clear explains that people
buy low emission or in the smarts case
no emission cars because they want to do
their part and keeping the urban
environment healthy she's enthusiastic
about the smarts philosophy and says you
really have to test drive it to
appreciate it just get in drive the
electric smart and you won't need her to
explain anything else it's a barrel of
fun Leon does I brush Class Mercedes has
plug-in hybrids too but Daimler decided
not to install alternative engine
technologies in the new e-class coupe a
its unveiling here
viaB dita sencha the head of
mercedes-benz says his company's e-class
sedan is a hybrid but not the coop a a
hybrid engine takes a lot of space that
would otherwise go to the trunk and a
coupe a already has little trunk space a
hybrid coupe a makes little sense and
Mercedes isn't planning one at the
moment he sees Tesla's who haven't
gotten the premium Japanese brand Lexus
has been competing directly with
Mercedes for two decades now in Detroit
lexus is presenting the fifth generation
of its luxury class sedan this car is
brand new from the ground up I mean
literally everything in that vehicle is
new from the wheels to the tires to the
aluminum panels which makes up so much
that vehicle to the engine the
transmission the interior everything is
brand new so we couldn't be more pleased
with the styling it looks beautiful but
beyond that once someone gets in that
vehicle and has a chance to drive it
they're gonna fall in love it that we
think many interior technical
refinements contribute to a pleasant
ride the LS 500 is powered by a 3.5
liter v6 twin-turbo gasoline engine
there is also a hybrid variant baba
wanta says the Japanese aren't the only
ones who can do that here in Detroit BMW
has unveiled its new five series hybrid
car this plug-in hybrid can travel 50
kilometers on electricity alone but it
also has a 135 kilowatt four-cylinder
gasoline engine the new top model of the
five series is the M 550i xdrive
[Music]
rinspeed and said f are presenting the
Oasis it's an agile self propelled
electric car with a small garden
integrated behind the windshield is this
a brilliant innovation or just the
marketing gag me of all from the
tennspeed CEO Frankland akash says his
company is about nothing but creativity
all day long employees go through life
with her eyes open he boasts they
discuss things give free rein to their
imaginations and take huge leaps it's
easier to backtrack than to look for
every next tiny idea incremental e
suppliers set F focuses on
electromobility and reducing traffic
accidents and emissions
in one's own fancy chairman Stefan
summer says the company's principal see
think and act means it doesn't restrict
its focus to sensors a new computer
technology it concentrates on the
mechanisms to implement physically on
the street what computers design in
terms of autonomous driving n VW it is
going through the biggest change in the
company's history along with the
extended seven-seat version of the t go
on the ID buzz is getting its premiere
here in Detroit
it's a VW marketing chief Jurgen
Stockman says the compact ID is one end
of the spectrum it has the same exterior
dimensions as a golf inside it's as big
as a passat this is the other end and
the coming months VW will show what
fills the range between the two poles
pacinos f you leave the Simon in East mu
nuttin the versatile vehicle has a six
hundred kilometer electric range and
plenty of other interesting features
Montes is the lack of a real dashboard
with instruments takes some getting used
to here everything is projected onto the
windshield the Sat Nav projection
structured so they appear as if they
were directly on the road a turn arrow
looks like it's actually in the
intersection Montes is sold this car is
funny says and he can't wait till it
comes onto the market probably in 2022
it's my own Swansea often marked calm